كيف ابني وطن من خلال بنك هذه قصه طلعت
حرب الراء الطلع
ه
في شبابه شاهد مجد وانهيار وانكسار الثوره
الاوروبيه ودي فتره كانت صعبه جدا في
تاريخ الشعب المصري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
استقبلت او زاد فيها عدد الاجانب من 32
الف سنه 1860 الى 144 الف سنه 1907 التجار
الاجانب زادوا من 133 سنه 1891 الى
2800 سنه 1917 فالحقيقه مصر كانت تحت يعني
وطئه اجنبيه شديده كان هناك يعني حمايه
اجنبيه لكل الجنسيات الاجانب عليهم حصانه
ولهم امتيازات لا ينطبق عليهم التشريعات
المصريه ولا ينطبق عليهم القوانين المصريه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لما يجي الانجليزي سنه 1910 عايزين يكتبوا
مذكره يقنعوا الحكومه بان هي من الخير لها
انها تمد الامتياز لشركه قناه السويس
اربعين سنه اخرى بعد 1868
فيتصدى طلعت حرب لهذا المنطق
المختل
ويفسد او يبطل هذا المشروع في الانجليزي
لم يغفره لهذا الكتاب
وظل ده احد الاسباب في محاوله التخلص منه
التي نجحت باخراج من بنك سنه 1939
[موسيقى]
طلعت حرب كتب الكتاب بتاعه علاج نصف
الاقتصادي في 1911 ونشر في 1913 مع ذلك
البنك توقفت الفكره للدعوه اليه ولم يتاسس
الا في 1920 دلاله كده ايه الفكره فضلت
كامنه خلال مرحله الحرب
وخلال الفتره اللي كان فيها يعني نوع من
الخمول السياسي النسبي في مصر
ما نشطتش تاني الا بعد 1919 هنا بقى نتنبه
لحاجه معينه ان طلعت حرب ادرك ان اللحظه
مناسبه لتقديم فكرته اول مصري يدير شركتي
اليهودي اللي كانوا دايما قافلين الدائره
عليهم كعائلات قبل ان ينتقل لتاسيس بنك
مصر ويخوض معركته العظيمه لانه واجهه
تحديات بلا حدود وسخريه بلا حدود كيف
يستطيع ان نكون بنك الامه بنك كل المصريين
[موسيقى]
في اي صاحب رساله كانس نفسه بهذه الرساله
خلي الموضوع جامد وكان بيشتغل كل يوم لمده
15 ساعه وقعد خمس سنوات لمده يعمل مجانا
فطلعت حرب امتلك القدره انه ما يكونش مجرد
تكنوقراطي وانما يكون شخص عنده الحس
التاريخي عنده الثقافه التاريخيه راس مال
بنك مصر عند تاسيسه 80,000 جنيه بس بهذا
المبلغ المتواضع نجح ان يجمع فئات كثيره
جدا بعضهم من اهل المدن وبعدهم من اعيان
الريف كان يصر على ان كل رجال العاملين في
بنك مصر ومصريين مسلمين مسيحيين يهود لكن
لازم يبقى مصري واللغه التي تستخدم فيها
اللغه العربيه
[موسيقى]
التاريخ الاقتصاد المصري الحديث هتلاقي ان
كل اصولها تعود الى طلاقها يكفي ان احنا
نذكر بالمحله الكبرى صناعه المسيح التامين
قطاع التامين لشركه مصر للتامين كل كلمه
مصر تلاقيها بما في ذلك استوديو مصر
وصناعه السينما
[موسيقى]
يحتاج اليها اكثر ما نحتاج في هذه الايام
احنا دلوقتي الناس كلها عماله بتقول هل
احنا دلوقتي مصر البنك الدولي
بيحركناش
واللي مش عارف التحالفات الدوليه او
العولمه طب احنا نقدر نعيش لوحدنا ولا
عايزين راس المال الاجنبي تقريبا الصوره
مشابهه لما كان في ايام طلعت حرب وطلعت
حرب حلها بالجهود الوطنيه المخلصه وقال
انا هشغل المصريين كل المتعلمين من مصر
بيقول هيشتغلوا في البنك وكان يطلق عليهم
جيش الخلاص الاقتصادي
من الطبقه المتوسطه التي كانت تمثل اماد
الحياه المصريه الى طبقه راسماليه دون ان
ينفصل عنها ودون ان يعني ايه ينفصل عن
تقاليده وعاداته يعني من اجمل صفاته انه
ظله ينتمي الى العادات والتقاليد الى
الجذور وهو لا يقاطع التحديث اذا هو صعبه
في مرحله تحولات الثوره السياسيه او
الثوره الوطنيه ثوره 19 ادرك انها لا يمكن
ان تتاثر وتتجذر الا
بالبعد الاقتصادي واهميه البعد الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
ظروف استقاله طلعت حرب ظروف ماساويه جدا
لانها بدات في كانت لسه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بتبدا بتاعه 1939
وكان فيه شيء يذكرك بالازمه الماليه
الحاليه وان يكن هناك
الازمه ديت القت بظلالها على المجتمع
الاقتصاد المصري المساله التانيه الصراعات
السياسيه
والاحتلال البريطاني لم يكن مرحبا
باستمرار بنك مصر كبنك وطني
وبالتالي
ضغط على الحكومه المصريه من اجل وضع نهايه
لهذا الحلم المصري العظيم
فتم فجاه بين يوم وليله تم تكالب على سحب
الودائع من البنك بما في ذلك مصلحه البريد
المصري اللي مصلحه حكوميه هيئه حكوميه
ويعني كان بالامكان ان هم يخرجوا البنك
ويقييدوه من عثرته
ويساعدوه على الاستمرار لكن هم رفضوا الا
بعد ان يترك طلعت حرب وكانما حقق المستشار
الانجليزي ما كان يرجو ان يتحقق طلعت حرب
رم اجمع عليه المصريين بمختلف اتجاهاتهم
السياسيه والاقتصاديه بتاع الحرب امشي
بثوره لكن هو قام باعمال تناظر بالضبط ما
قامت به الثوره درس صناعه النجاح رغم كل
التحديات
درس ان قوه الوطن فيما يمتلك وليس فيما
يستدين وليس في القروب